hey David Nancy Pelosi says that gun
control will be a priority for the new
Democratic House in 2019
is this a good idea is the political
risk worth the possibility of actually
accomplishing anything excellent
question
okay earlier this week we talked about
what should the Democratic agenda be for
the incoming Congress and parallel to
that it's not the same but it's parallel
what should the Democratic platform be
for 2020 this question is about the
agenda what should and this is presuming
I believe that Nancy Pelosi becomes
Speaker of the House for the Democrats
what should the agenda be of the
Democrats once they are sworn back in
and take over control we've talked about
the issue of gun rights before many
times is voting our is is it a voting
issue when politicians talk about gun
rights I think that it only is when the
position is seen as very extreme doesn't
mean that it's actually a very extreme
position but as bill scher has told us
and as others have told us voting rights
does not really seem to translate into
getting people to vote one way or the
other
assuming once again that what they are
portrayed is supporting or being against
that their position is not being
portrayed as absolutely and totally
outrageous and as we we talked about
this week
Democrats need to understand that at a
certain point I know that there are
there's sort of a sliding scale of
idealism and pragmatism I am often
criticized by some on the left for being
too much on the pragmatism side I have
criticized others for being too far on
the idealism side I think that there
needs to be a mix so are there some
single-issue voters who would change
their vote because of the gun safety
stuff that Democrats do or try to do
during the next Congress it's possible
but when only 50% of the country votes
they are not going to swing the election
and you can more than outdo them simply
by focusing on voter turnout so the
pragmatist reality is much of what the
Democrats would
proposed in the house wouldn't make it
through a Republican Senate period so
then the question very quickly becomes
what can you actually achieve and what
would be the political risk of doing
that as the question is my approach
would be try to get some wins and I
don't want to call them
small wins because these are important
things but they are not necessarily the
biggest things that the left would want
to do 100 percent background checks and
a mandatory waiting period okay it's
possible that if you negotiate with
senators if you figure out a way to get
Trump on board even if it's by sure
confusion and not understanding what
what it is that's being proposed which
is absolutely fine does the guy
understand anything that's being
proposed you might be able to do 100
percent background checks and a
mandatory waiting period and it might
unfortunately have to be wrapped in to
some other bill or packaged with
unrelated stuff that is how it doesn't
have to be that way but that's how they
have chosen to do a lot of this stuff
and it's an it's unfortunate could you
maybe get an age limit where if you're
under 21 you can't buy semi-automatic
rifles I don't know if you can do that
that that would those three things
100% background checks no 20 no 21 year
old no 21 and under under 21 buying
semi-automatic rifles and a mandatory
waiting period that actually would have
reduced or or prevented or made
extraordinarily more unlikely some of
the mass shootings that we have had and
then think about making more progress in
2020 if the election goes well and you
take over the House and Senate that
would be my advice which is a balance
between actually trying to make some
accomplishments without risking
alienation of voters over over that
issue one of today's sponsors is
Skillshare which is an incredible online
learning community offering over 10,000
high-quality online courses on a huge
variety of topics first 500 who click
the link under this video will get two
entire months of totally free access to
every single class that Skillshare
offers you'll
have free access to courses on music art
photography business computer
programming cooking meditation and
everything in between I think you'll
have no problem finding courses that are
perfect for you just took a really great
class on graphic design which I know
nothing about but I'm trying to learn
our show is giving you two entire months
of totally free access to every course
Skillshare offers risk free if you click
the link under this video you'll have
two months to take classes on anything
you're passionate about classes taught
by real people who share that passion
and after that you can keep getting
access to the entire site for less than
ten bucks a month
just click the link under this video to
redeem your to three months of skill
share but hurry it's only available to
the first 500 who sign up